hello Internet welcome to a real rejects
reaction to film Theory we are gonna
watch from the film theorists dear DC I
fixed your Universe again we did a
reaction to uh the one from uh around
the time standard cut came out and now
we're here to see what Matt Patton the
crew has to say John how are you I'm
good Greg how are you
let's get to it leave a like
[Music]
the DC Universe is broken Superman is
lost Black Adam stayed in the red cyborg
has been silenced Wonder Woman has
vanished Into Thin Air and the Flash has
gotten into so much trouble that DC
wishes he'd just run his way into an
entirely new timeline
and the key to solving all of it
cartoons wrists
do this hello Internet interesting
Theory already Fury the show that wants
you to subscribe faster than the flash
but you can't do it and write your
favorite superhero down in the comments
in less than three seconds three two
wait you did it dang you are faster than
a speeding bullet you're giving us time
you're giving us time remember but there
was a time not too long ago when DC was
the top dog when it came to superhero
movies Remember The Dark Knight trilogy
those movies made over 2.4 billion
dollars at the box office one of them
was so good that when it wasn't
nominated for best picture at the Oscars
the academy literally changed their
rules to avoid anything like that ever
happening again but uh in the following
years yeah yeah not so much the dceu
which officially started with Man of
Steel 10 years ago has been an absolute
mess and that's not meant to be a
judgment call or measure of quality I
mean just as a point of fact right now
there are three different Batman and two
separate Jokers running around at the
same time
you started it's been a nightmare of
hiring firing and rehiring multiple
directors for the same project actor is
being let go brought back again only to
be let go again there's been public
Fallout over bad behavior by Studio
Executives constant cameos and teases
for films that'll never happen while
completely finished movies are just
outright canceled meanwhile you got star
actors dealing with felony allegations
popping up like the worst game of life
quality of some of these things is WB
stock price which got so low that it was
basically sold for spare parts to the
guy who runs the Discovery Channel gotta
be honest here loyal theorists as
someone who grew up loving DC's Heroes
more than Marvel's it's been really
heartbreaking to see this I'm not gonna
lie you know I've been hearing for like
10 years now that the DC Universe has
been uh really Rocky you know I can get
caught up in things like the Batman
Joker Aquaman being a big hit the first
Wonder Woman movie me personally loving
the Snyder vs Ultimate Edition of bvs
that is yeah but when you put it like
that you're like oh yeah yeah it's
better [__] show yeah yeah but it's
pretty much every step of the way and
even the more agreeable steps have been
marred by some type of controversy or or
Battle of opinions like every Studio has
a [__] show that time I'm like oh I
don't know it's been uh it's been it's
been a big fight yeah yeah and I didn't
even realize like the whole how dire
their stock had gotten too and yeah like
it affects their business as well as
just everyone's enjoyment of DC even
like the suicide squad like I love that
but I'm like but it wasn't a hit it
wasn't a big hit and it's confusing they
already had Suicide Squad okay but now
there's New Hope Warner Brothers has
brought on James Gunn writer and
director of Guardians of the Galaxy The
Suicide Squad and Peacemaker to Shepherd
their movies back to financial and
critical success and well he certainly
has a long path ahead of him to get the
DC Universe back to where it needs to be
I think he can do it provided he follows
my advice today that's right today I
plan to give this new master of the
universe a five-point guide on how to
make a successful DC cinematic franchise
and I'm not just pulling this from
anywhere I have proof that these steps
will work let's hear it super suits and
kiss your Martha's goodbye save
ourselves a franchise shall we hey there
theorists future matpat here for the
second film theory in a row go figure so
literally just a couple hours ago as I
write this James Gunn came out and did a
big presentation talked about DC's
future plans announcing 10 new projects
for Gods and Monsters the so-called
first chapter of their big DC reboots
mind you this is a couple days after we
wrote and recorded this and got the
audio out to our editors announcement
kind of came out of nowhere usually they
preface this sort of stuff or try to
time it around Big Industry events but
nope this was him just dropping a big
old promotional bomb in the middle of
everyone so what I'm gonna be doing now
is laying out my advice exactly as it
was written not changing the script at
all but then at the end of each section
I'm gonna pop back in to assess how guns
seems to be handling things going
forward does it look like he's taken our
advice is he ignoring it and doing his
own thing or is he falling into the
mistakes of his predecessors let's just
jump back into the theory and find out
film theorists you knew he was gonna
announce [__] in January he's been
saying that since December you you could
have waited you could have waited yeah
January is enough of a big event it's a
new year you knew yeah you knew
something was coming this falls on you
team you're all lazy you need to be on
the internet more look at these videos
snow work goes into them at all up your
game all right maybe you'll find success
one of these days step
on take care of your Heavy Hitters both
in terms of care
well as the 10 behind them
and pop strong brand identity most
people know who's Superman Batman Wonder
Woman Aquaman and the Flash are heck
even Green Lantern so at least guitar
your focus needs to be on revitalizing
most of the core cast with strong movies
or series it's not to say that I don't
think a cyborg or a Black Adam or a
birds of prey can work on screen but why
would people go to see those if you
can't even get Superman right right now
DC needs to rebuild the audience's trust
they need to let them know that they're
delivering fun high quality movies
consistently with all the name brands
that we know and love then and only then
will people start to come out for the
second stringers I mean case in point
just look at Marvel phase one you gotta
do your Captain America's and Thor's
Justice before anyone gives the talking
tree and Sassy rabbit a chance the
Marvel Brand can carry smaller
characters now all that said the other
side of the coin is after you've done a
few of your core characters Justice if a
creative comes along and has an amazing
pitch for something more obscure may end
up making c-list characters like animal
man or the Doom Patrol into household
names and we know that DC is capable of
this look no further than exam it had a
great story with a likable tone and a
strong cast and now you're seeing him
enter the cultural Zeitgeist more and
more even more obscure before the
suicide squad no one had ever heard of a
peacemaker but now he's played by a
world famous wrestler and has his own
popular TV show my mom has heard of
Peacemaker again Marvel has routinely
done this when they didn't have the
rights to their biggest names like
Spider-Man or the X-Men they looked at
their second stringers the core Avengers
cast used to be the guys that cameo'd in
the Spider-Man cartoons now they're all
huge franchises of their own right and I
don't just mean Iron Man and Captain
America here either they've turned the
Scarlet Witch chongqi Moon Knight and
the Guardians of the Galaxy into brands
that are big enough to carry their own
films TV shows and theme park rides
Kevin feige's gone on record saying that
when they're deciding which characters
to adapt it doesn't matter how famous or
popular the character is in the comics
only that there's great potential for a
movie story should always come first
alright future map hat with the
assessment yes
well it kind of remains to be seen
though there was a big focus on projects
like the new iterations the core cast
with Superman Legacy and the Brave and
the Bold there was also a surprisingly
large amount of obscure stuff thrown in
the mix Swamp Thing Booster Gold even
though swampeding a little that's
predictable they're Heavy Hitters right
he told deadline in one of the
interviews quote one of our strategies
is that we take our Diamond characters
Batman Superman Wonder Woman and we use
that to help prop up other characters
that people don't know and thus we get
ourselves Creature Commandos So in
theory in superhero theory he seems to
get it but we'll see how things pan out
well you got to keep in mind too that
he's also leading into the current films
that are coming out as well like things
like Flashpoint Aquaman 2 and Shazam
Fury of the Gods and like Blue Beetle
maybe not blue beetles I was like
household of a name for sure you got the
Flash movie and Aquaman 2 and he is
citing those films as something that is
important to entering the DCU as well
it's not surprising that he would go
into Creature Commandos next so if it
was just a oh we're gonna can all those
movies and we're going to start fresh
then I would think okay then you start
with Superman Legacy but because he's
got those other uh four films to segue
into this I think that's why it's
kicking off what creature command does
makes more sense guarding the theory
that you have yeah and then you can do a
little bit of Justice to the flagship or
something before Justice yeah you know
the people who came before who you know
are sort of in limbo as to whether they
will persist and then yeah you can put
in your own personality after those are
out in the world and then give that as
lead up to something like a Superman or
whatever which leads me to my next piece
of advice number two trust the source
material the fans love these characters
and they have loved these characters
it's your job to understand why what is
the core value of that character to the
audience and then once you understand
what that is do not change it there are
so many recent examples of people using
IP without any sort of respect for the
source material isn't that right Velma
for instance Superman the symbol of
truth justice in the American way should
not be destroying full city blocks or
snap and necks in a gritty drama I like
this movie
struggle that's the conflict that the
movie has to explore throughout its run
time the character who's determined to
be purely good is suddenly forced into
positions where he has to question his
own ethical line that is an interesting
movie it's the superhero version of the
trolley problem dig into that because it
plays into what Superman can save all
those people it's unironic unspoiled
sense of pure goodness and hope don't
just leave it as some sort of footnote
to happen at the end of the film if you
want an example of what not to do take a
look at Netflix's The Witcher it started
out great with Henry Cavill a beloved
actor and fan of the material stepping
in to play the title character but
things quickly devolved as the creatives
started changing parts of the Witcher
Mythos to the point that rumors started
swirling that the writers hated their
Source material that right there is what
we call a big red flag and the fan
reviews for both season two and the
spin-off blood Origins reflect that is
it any wonder that Henry Cavill bowed
out of the franchise that he loved so he
could go work on a Warhammer adaptation
he even released a public statement
saying quote I promise to respect this
IP that we love I promise to bring you
something thing familiar it's not a good
look for the creative team over at The
Witcher huh it also looked like he uh
bowed out to become Superman yeah it
really looked like
taken care of for the next 10 years
because I believe the Warhammer one came
after leaving Witcher and the Superman
uh leaving that as well he just walked
into his room in frustration picked up
the first game and was like this is my
new franchise in short audiences aren't
dumb they can tell when something's made
with a genuine love for the IP so if you
find out that your writer staff can't be
bothered to pick up and read some comic
books then just stop what you're doing
stop it right there and find a project
that they are excited about or you know
scrap the whole team and get someone who
actually wants the project you know a
character that has some ridiculous lore
Sonic the Hedgehog but both Sonic movies
have embraced that video game weirdness
to deliver movies that are in the top 10
highest grossing for the year they
respected The Source materials thinking
of that Sonic lore by the way if you're
interested in just how crazy Sonic lore
gets and how the newest games release
breaks all of it we just released a game
theory about that very topic link is in
the top right corner of the screen make
sure you watch that one after we're done
solving the DC eu's problems you see
that kind of happens a lot with certain
IPS that the higher screen right because
a lot of times you're like recording
screenwriters and stuff but the
screenwriter themselves will they will
do the research and dive into the source
material it ends up not clicking with
them and they don't really like it so
they just want to do a big change it's
my take of what I would like what it
would make me actually like this story
yeah so you gotta find the right
screenwriters who dive into the source
material for their research to adapt
even if they're not like prior fans of
the source material but if they dive
into it and then they really do connect
with it emotionally and like it so that
way they know what's good about it and
then they have to figure out how to
translate that to film versus I don't
like this I want to make it my own I
almost feel like it would be more
practical to give a few writers The
Source material and then let them all
pitch you scripts and see who's got the
most before green lighting one or the
other problem is like even if they dive
into the source material they might just
be coming too analytical like why do
people like this but I feel like the
writer themselves has to have like a
heart connection to it you know future
map back again happy to say that I think
Gunn Nails this point the new Superman
Project seems to be borrowing for more
hopeful Stories the Brave and the Bold
is bringing more of Batman's very
popular Family characters on the screen
and embracing stranger parts of the
Obscure IP they're adapting awesome even
that Supergirl movie is adapting a
really new really weird story that fans
and critics loved borrowing more from
stuff like John Carter than Smallville
on paper everything here is looking
great which makes a lot of sense I mean
we're talking about a guy who made a
talking raccoon alien tree and polka dot
man work on film if there was any one of
these five points that he was gonna
knock out of the park it was gonna be
this one now back to the advice Point
number three and this is a bit of a
corollary to what we just talked about
if a character doesn't fit a tone Don't
force him into a movie with that tone
basically I don't want to try to ram a
Superman shaped block through a
batman-shaped hole despite both of them
being superheroes the types of stories
they tell aren't anywhere close to the
same something I don't think a lot of
people understand about Marvel's output
is that they aren't superhero movies
they're movies with superheroes in them
sure and they do have consistent factors
but superhero isn't the genre instead
Marvel looks at their characters and
then writes stories about them in genres
that make sense to really explain what I
mean let's just take a look at three of
the franchises Captain America Ant-Man
and Spider-Man all three of these series
have Marvel's trademark quippy humor
costume design art Direction all that
jazz but the types of stories they're
telling are all very different Winter
Soldier and Civil War are political
Thrillers making commentary on serious
social issues this isn't Freedom there's
worse ways to protect people protection
is that how you see this he's not a U.S
citizen and they don't Grant visas to
weapons give me a break both Ant-Man
films are heist movies featuring Scott
Lang breaking into somewhere highly
secure to either steal something or
rescue someone my days of breaking
and both of these franchises are way
different from the Spider-Man movies
which are all gen Z John Hughes Coming
of Age films who's this
she's the best she's awesome yeah she's
just a girl who goes to my school the
stakes are different the structures are
different the genres are different so
how does that apply let's say watch
quantumania guys the Christopher Nolan
Batman Trilogy are crime Thrillers Matt
Reeves is the Batman leaned into the
Noir elements of a detective story both
of them were dark and gritty and
rightfully so but the problem begins
when you start to layer that tone across
a whole franchise Wonder Woman Shazam
Superman they're not gritty characters
so trying to layer them in one gritty
Shazam I'm gonna create tonal conflict
this was arguably one of the biggest
issues with the early phases of the dceu
Zack Snyder's aesthetic was being
applied like a filter over everything
the genre of those early movies and all
the lessons took wrong from The Dark
Knight nothing really more but if you
look at the movies in the franchise that
worked the best Shazam Wonder Woman
Aquaman and The Suicide Squad they
weren't afraid to break from the mold
and carve out their own tone Wonder
Woman the good one was part periods
Aquaman borrowed a lot already before
adventure movies like Indiana Jones and
the mummy and audiences loved both of
the those ocean Man movie has drum
playing octopus awesome kids superhero
movie has YouTube humor perfect talking
shark movie has giant alien starfish
enemy cool just because everyone in the
DC EU shares a collective World it
doesn't mean that everyone's part in
that world needs to share the same tone
it's actually a really solid point
because even when you get a movie like
Captain America Civil War which is a lot
of people consider like an Avengers 2.0
in a lot of ways right because there's
so many other Avengers characters in
there they still fit it into that genre
I think the you know like the mainly the
mashup movies like but but even like
Infinity war is a certain what genre
would you call Infinity War it is a war
movie and a bit of a kind of a heist
Thriller I mean the Russo brothers are
applying that yeah that game is too yeah
you know well that's I think the thing
that that isn't good about this point is
because yeah you have the individual
characters who can take place in their
own Universe with its tone and then you
get the problem but also the opportunity
of yet doing a crossover where you get
to decide okay what is a tone that all
these characters can mean between but I
think Zack Snyder found that with Zack
Snyder's Justice League though because I
get what he's saying is like don't try
to make every individual property fit
that tone yeah you know it shouldn't
just be all Batman be Superman's or
something like that in tone like all of
phase one does not feel like the first
Avengers movie yeah you know or the
first Iron Man or something yeah yeah
it's like you have to have your
individual franchises and then you have
a specific tone for your Unity films you
need to look at the characters that
you're working with and then make movies
around them not force them into the
movies that you're trying to make so
make an upbeat Superman action film with
a journalist make a space cop action
drama Lantern just give them all room to
breathe and do their own thing future
map hat Review Time DC's approach to
this one seems perfect not only are they
letting stuff like the Batman and Joker
sit in their own worlds with their own
tone you see searing over the only parts
of the DC EU that people loved Aquaman
Wonder Woman Shazam and The Suicide
Squad plus they are very clearly
embracing different tones in the new
adaptations that they're bringing to the
table even have the same idea for that
True Detective in space version of Green
Lantern that we just pitched right there
gonna like Han James piece of advice
number four this is a big one take your
time take your time making the movies
good duh but also more importantly take
your time announcing what you're working
on that way you can see what works what
audiences react positively to and what
you need to work on behind the scenes if
something doesn't pan out all without
publicly embarrassing everyone involved
seems obvious right you would think but
a lot of Studios make this mistake see
the MCU had this weird marketing
strategy for a film franchise when it
was still young they'd have Kevin feige
come out because little Kevin the entire
next three to five years of movies all
at once at the time when they were still
growing their brand it worked really
well for them it got fans excited which
built up hype but this taught the other
Studios the wrong lessons everyone
wanted a piece of the pie and so they
tried their best to start the next MCU
ASAP Universal might just be the best
worst example of this that I can think
of their classic monster movies under
the Dark Universe Banner back in the
mid-2010s they announced half a dozen
movies I gotta remember that yeah they
did a whole photo shoot Hollywood
Superstars like Tom Cruise Johnny Depp
Angelina Jolie they even released a
star-studded cast photo of the major
players all in one place so you knew
that they were serious about it fun fact
by the way none of those actors were
actually in the same room for this photo
shoot they were just photoshopped
together anyway the one thing that
Universal didn't do in all this make
sure the movies that launched the
franchise were actually worth watching
Dracula Untold was a moderate financial
success but was eviscerated by critics
and fans and the mummy starring Tom
Cruise it did even worse the most
memorable thing about that movie was the
trailer they mistakenly uploaded without
any audio
hell
yep that was a real keep it alive
exploded by a real major movie studio
all in all 51 million awesome star power
they had lined up Universal did not take
their time building up this IP and as a
result people looked at the Dark
Universe and said I'm not interested in
that at all DC did the exact same thing
in 2014 they announced 10 movies for
their new universe spearheaded by Zack
Snyder ranging from Wonder Woman and
Aquaman to Shazam and Cyborg some were
as far away as six years the only
problem with this they didn't actually
wait to see how people like the first
couple movies cue the internal executive
scramble Studio interference replacing
director shifting schedules delays
cancellations and public embarrassment
all of them were self-inflicted wounds
that were totally avoidable Warner
Brothers didn't need to go out and
announce 10 movies they could have just
gone with three or four seen how people
like the first stab at things and then
privately changed plans in the
background when it became clear that
audiences weren't clicking with the DC
EU see I feel like you're about to say
that you know James Gunn did not do that
and I was surprised too by the uh amount
of announcements that there were because
there was a lot and I thought he was
gonna announce like four films yeah not
ten properties
I was surprised by that because I'm like
that is a lot to commit to yeah yeah
you're pitching a lot of different ideas
and the problem then becomes they're all
different and yet even one of them
failing is enough to at least with what
we know about how WB tends to react to
things it's enough to you know cause a
scramble and then a bunch of reworking
spiritually this is the one that makes
future map had a little worried I'm
skeptical about the fact that so many
projects just got announced this week
another 10 in total which is just like
that initial wave of DC EU announcements
that being said I suppose they're not
completely starting from scratch here
they are bringing what worked from the
DC EU over into this new universe so at
least they're starting on a positive
note plus I also found this quote where
guns said that they're willing to delay
movies if the scripts aren't 100 ready
now I would hope that this would
normally be the default in Hollywood but
look Blockbusters over the last decade
clearly not but I won't be getting too
far ahead of myself because piece of
advice number five don't have a
long-term plan not kidding don't
meticulously plan out the new universe
so you know exactly what's supposed to
happen and when I know it sounds
counterproductive but I promise that
you'll regret doing this by having so
much of your franchise laid out you
don't give yourself room to maneuver if
something changes that you want to
insert into the franchise or a writer
comes along to offer you a great story
that otherwise doesn't fit again you can
learn from Marvel here and the big
example I'm going to point to is Captain
America Civil War this was a huge movie
for the franchise basically Avengers 2.5
featuring The culmination of a ton of
stories and setting up a ton of others
for the future from the outside looking
in it might have seemed like they
planned the whole thing from the start
but they didn't Civil War wasn't even
the original pitch the writers wanted to
adapt a different Captain America story
called mad bomb but fikey didn't think
that it went big enough so things
pivoted to Civil War and even then there
were more I did not know that with and
without Spider-Man since Marvel was busy
negotiating with the character with Sony
and if they hadn't come to an agreement
there Ant-Man would have switched sides
to become team Iron Man thereby changing
his entire character Arc in all the
future movies but Marvel just decided to
go with the flow and did what worked in
the moment now that's not to say that
you shouldn't have a vague idea of what
to do or where your story is going you
100 should so you can build to it Marvel
did exactly that in Hulk and Iron Man 1
teasing The Avengers Initiative because
they knew that eventually they were
going to have a crossover they just
didn't have what was going to happen in
The Avengers laid out and then the
Avengers movies yeah exactly because
that Marvel knew that eventually they'd
want him to be a big bad but writing out
how exactly they were going to get their
beat for Beats that's no bueno seriously
did you know that for a while nobody at
Marvel had decided where the Infinity
Stones were or even what was and wasn't
an infinity stone true story according
to tweets from James Gunn himself when
they first shot Guardians of the Galaxy
the infinity stone in the movie was red
the color of the reality but most had to
be changed to the purple Power Stone
because Marvel had decided after the
fact that the red one would be coming
from Thor the Dark world's ether heck
they didn't even know why Thanos wanted
the stones to kill half the universe
until they sat down like the script for
Infinity War
you need any more proof of their lack of
a plan they featured The Infinity
Gauntlet in Odin's vault as early as
phase one the last time
and it was retcon which when you think
about it is kind of funny because this
then is a fake of a gauntlet that hadn't
even been built yet I made what he
wanted device
capable of harnessing the power that's a
fascinating Point yeah come over from a
Multiverse final future map hat review
I'm not too worried there even though
they did talk about plans to have
characters appear in multiple projects
Gunn didn't come out and announce a
giant crossover event that everything's
leading up yes that's like I'm just
gonna go with the flow for now which I
think is the smart option static bad
there is still one final big thing that
I want to point out the gun here so that
is a lot of advice but here's the
biggest Twist of them all DC already has
the perfect blueprint to model parts of
this new Cinematic Universe from and
it's followed basically all of this
advice it was called the DC animated UK
If you grew up with DC in the 90s James
Gunn said he's inspired by it guys this
franchise it's where a lot of the iconic
modern portrayals of DC's characters
originated Kevin Conroy's Batman Mark
Hamill's Joker those were these versions
of Batman and Joker before they made
their way into the animated films and
Arkham video games so how does the DC Au
follow my advice
yes they knew that the Heavy Hitters
were
and then they grew into a Superman show
before they had the two of them Team Up
In Justice League but what else did they
do well an awesome new character named
static came along in the comics and they
jumped at the chance to adapt him with a
creative team that were excited to tell
his stories and when the really weird
but really cool idea for a cyberpunk
Batman spin-off came along they made
Batman Beyond they also let less
important characters shine in the
Justice League shows seriously Hawkgirl
the question etragram the demon all
minor characters that had leading roles
episodes even entire story arcs devoted
to them not only that but they adapted
these characters in ways that didn't
pigeonhole him into tones that didn't
fit they let Batman have a darker more
Noir tone Superman was more upbeat in
sci-fi static shock didn't feel the same
as Batman Beyond which also didn't feel
the same as Justice League fourthly they
took their time building the world
Batman the Animated Series was first
released in 1993. Superman didn't get
his spin-off until 1996 and Justice
League didn't come along until 2001.
great [__] DC Au head honcho Bruce Tim
might have had ideas on where to take
the universe's Story the creators didn't
plan beyond what seasons and shows had
already been greenlits they didn't go
into Batman in the early 90s mapping out
yeah exactly exactly exactly yeah
exactly I was gonna take them listen DC
James you guys have a golden opportunity
here to take some of the most beloved
characters an IP in the world and make
something really meaningful it won't be
easy but exactly how to do it is right
in front of you all you need to do is
follow my advice just go watch some
great old cartoons I mean for ages
people have been saying like the
animated movies or the animated
franchise of the DC Universe has been
the thing that DC ought to model you
know um even like you and koi reacted to
like suicide squad uh I know a Batman
assaults on Arkham and I remember when
that came out I watched that because
some people were telling me that this is
what Suicide Squad movie should have
been and then I watched that I'm like oh
yeah yeah
I see it that's just like an example of
one property event in terms of like
connective universes and building them
out yeah I think the DC Animated
Universe um all across the board has
been one of the Best Bets to for a road
map to follow when James Gunn himself
has said that he's taken a lot of
inspiration from it as well so yeah I
feel like this video is quite accurate
absolutely to a lot of what uh the team
at film theory was hoping for so guys
subscribe to film theorists uh leave a
like on this video but before we go
let's end this with a
you gotta ask the niso love it to be
your Valentine Anisa I'm a lonely
hearted guy and you are the only
brightness in my life you have been
there through thick and thin at the
reject Nation always with a smile always
with support always sharing your life
with us you've sent us so many lovely
gifts and trinkets from Texas I want to
send you my heart so I'm gonna put that
in the mail for you and uh when you get
it you let me know and that'll be my cue
to come out find the nearest most
sincere gas station in all of Texas
that's right it's coming back and there
in the bathroom we are going to have a
nice candle lit dinner I'm gonna warm up
some of those microwave burritos they
have at the gas station Counter and then
you and I we're gonna do like a little
lady in the [__] thing but with the
burrito instead of spaghetti it's gonna
be delicious and uh yeah I I'm gonna
shower you in potpourri and uh you know
we're gonna we're gonna make we're gonna
hold ends till the moon light to the to
the day break
and it's going to be romantic and
beautiful and uh and yeah and just be my
be
[Music]